bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien
sur france24 notre invité aujourd'hui et
le ministre tunisien de l'économie et de
la planification monsieur samir sayyed
merci d'être avec nous monsieur le
ministre mais aussi à vous monsieur le
ministre il ya des inquiétudes sur la
situation économique mondiale mais aussi
tunisienne et la crise du coc vide il
est la crise en ukraine il y a beaucoup
de craintes parmi les populations de
l'inflation d'une crise qui est à
l'horizon est ce que vous êtes vous même
inquiet
nous comprenons la situation la
situation est difficile dans la plupart
des pays du monde parce que l'amour la
situation a été aggravée par la dernière
guerre du collège pour les pays
importateurs de l'énergie et de matières
de base
le peut-être la difficulté de la tunisie
c'est que l essai venu dans un contexte
difficile d'appeler covit et lequel
coville lui même est intervenue après
les attentats 2015 et après un pic à 2
de croissance faible ou bien de
stagnation donc nous vivons une décade
de transition démocratique mon pays le
bris et c'est pas un pli cher pour la
démocratie et pour la liberté aulas sud
est nous considérons que ces chocs sont
des chocs externes donc essentiellement
conjoncturelle et nous allons adresser
les problèmes structurels ça ne veut pas
dire qu'on n'a pas de problèmes
structurels nous en sommes conscients
donc nous sommes en train de travailler
sur un plan national de réformes
structurelles pour pouvoir remettre le
pays sur la trajectoire des équilibres
financiers à moyen terme et rétablir la
confiance totale dans notre économie
mais est ce que justement ce plan sur
lequel vous travaillez n'est pas
percuter j'allais dire par la nouvelle
réalité qui découle de la guerre en
ukraine est ce que tout n'est pas remis
en cause finalement au contraire plus
que jamais nous avons besoin d'accélérer
c'est le forum aujourd'hui donc ce qu'on
avait ajouté par rapport aux réformes
structurelles c'est des millions de gens
ce qu on avait pris récemment même avant
la guerre de grandeur que nous devrons
renforcer on avons comme nous avons
commencé à les renforcer nous avons
annoncé le 1er avril caron 2000 de jans
économique et qui adresse le volet
financier parce que nos pme n'ont pas eu
le support suffisant pour pouvoir
vraiment faire face aux effets de la
crise qu vite on va relancer
l'investissement public et privé on va
simplifier et faciliter nos procédures
nos procédures sont compliquées nous
avons notre lot de l'eau classique nous
devons atténuer et nous allons renforcer
la croissance de l'export parce que
aujourd'hui plus que jamais nous avons
besoin export nous avons besoin de
croissance et le nez de l'export c'est
que c'est consommer ailleurs donc on ne
vit pas ou ne vivra plus au dessus de
nos moyens comme ça a été le cas mais
trop trop longtemps peut-être d'autres
au contraire nous
penchant sur le renforcement de ses
mesures d'urgence à côté de travaux du
plan que sont en train d'avancer de la
vision 20 35 également que kick est
quasiment plein alors c'est bien toutes
ces réformes il vous faut de l'argent
vous négociez depuis un bon moment avec
le fonds monétaire international
4 milliards de dollars vous étiez vous
même à washington a récemment les
négociations n'ont toujours pas abouti
vous avez besoin de cet argent quand est
ce qu'il y aura enfin un accord avec le
fmi laissé tout à fait normal que les
discussions prennent du temps parce
qu'il faut film à l'enseigné quand même
non je pense que c'est au contraire
c'est une assurance pour vraiment
assurer les conditions de succès de ces
réformes cet effort malheureusement qui
ont été retardés longtemps donc
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
l'obligation de les mener aux parallèles
et le fait de rentrer dans le détail
c'est ce qu'on est en train de faire
avec les familles maintenant c'est une
forme d'assurance pour nous également
pour réussir c'est le fort parce que
aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus droit à
l'erreur que nous avons l'intention de
réussir l'implémentation dans cette fois
quand on sait là nous avons déjà
commencé mais quand il y aura dix sept
d'accord avant le fmi va-t-il dire ok
voilà les quatre jeux je pense que c'est
une question de semaines pas question de
plusieurs mois et je pense que le fait
mis à communiquer là dessus ils ont bien
exprimé que ils sont relativement
satisfaits de l'avancement de
préparation des réformes de l'homme nous
à part du gouvernement qui jongle ici
quelques semaines ça dépend le
calendrier c'est pas moi qui le fixe par
la tunisie qu'il fixe c'est entre les
deux entités et nous sommes confiants
que nous allons aboutir ce qui est plus
important à mon avis est d'aboutir à un
accord avec les familles beaucoup plus
important que la voir la semaine
prochaine ou dans trois mois nous
pouvons
gérer la situation même si c'est des
conditions difficiles encore une fois
pour des conditions exogènes nous
comprenons très bien c'était mais s'est
exaucé conjoncturelle nous trouverons le
moyen de faire face mais nous sommes
confiants que nous avons fait le
nécessaire pour amener les réformes qui
convainc nous parlant les familles
convainc également nos partenaires
financiers qui sont en train de nous
soutenir et je les remercie pendant
cette période un soutien vraiment que
mon pc doit pas de la banque mondiale de
l'abbaye de labeur de la bad donc
islamique des gens c'était la liste est
longue donc elle économise les médias
nous fait confiance on ne risque pas de
s'effondrer dans les mois qui viennent
on en entend des mauvais mois en moyenne
on entend des inquiétudes on en parle
pas d'effondrement nous sommes en train
de faire le nécessaire pour réformer
toutes les causes toutes les sources de
ces déséquilibres financiers nous sommes
conscients je ne nie pas les problèmes
je ne nie pas le coup c'est des
problèmes sérieux et que nous pouvons
plus différer leur traitement mais nous
faisons tout le nécessaire parce que les
gouvernements précédents on met la
poussière sous le tapis bon je dirais
qu'on a eu un défaut d'implémentation
les villes dit poliment mais c'est ça ou
la conception je pense qu'il n'y a pas
beaucoup de choses nouvelles les six
formes sont connus je pense que les
sociétés étatiques la réforme de la
fonction publique la forme de
subventions énergétique ou bien produits
de base la réforme de l'étude de la
justice puisque à la réalisation de ce
qu'elle était et les équilibres des
caisses de sécurité sociale on les
connaît depuis longtemps donc pourquoi
on ne va pas implémentées
une question que effectivement légitime
malheureusement leur grille le profond
regret qu'on a on a tout retardé
d'insérer fort et donc maintenant
l'implantation leur implémentation sera
plus difficile mais elle n'est pas
impossible et nous avons déjà commencé à
implémenter alors parmi les conditions
où les discussions avec le fmi on sait
qu'il ya des mesures difficiles
notamment pour le quotidien des
tunisiens est-ce que les subventions
vont être supprimés ou limitée est ce
qu'il y aura par exemple un gel des
salaires dans un
cadre inflationnistes comme on le vit
actuellement ça risque de très mal passé
auprès des tunisiens très bien je
voudrais parler de la subvention et
clarifier cette question là parce que le
malheureusement beaucoup d'intox là
dessus et n'a jamais été question de
supprimer des subventions il s'agit
simplement de réorienter les subventions
vers les familles nécessiteuses
aujourd'hui nous avons une subvention de
pays qui bénéficie à tout le monde et
qui bénéficie même d'un des pays
africains nos pays voisins dont on a
trouvé nos produits de subventionner
dans des pays africains très loin de là
que vous allez faire le tri et ça ça
nous coûte énormément d'argent donc le
fait de transformer la scène le support
des prix vers les familles nécessiteuses
ça nous permettra d'augmenter
progressivement les plis je dis bien
progressivement les prix après avoir
versé des compensations aux familles
nécessiteuses nous sommes nous avançons
sur la réforme on est avancé dans la
préparation de la plateforme qui va
permettre une base vente à tous les
tunisiens qui s'estiment ont besoin de
support de s'inscrire et à partir de là
nous commençons d'abord à subventionner
données de let et ensuite augmenter
progressivement le pays et donc on fera
dans l'ordre le jeu insiste là-dessus et
plus au fur et à mesure qu'on avance on
va faire un tri au niveau de cette base
de données et plus on a une la vraie
base de données sélectionnées plus on
augmentera ce support donc n'y aura plus
souvent sont généralisés le gel des
salaires mais je tiens à dire également
que le différentiel de prix entre le
prix subventionnés et le plie de marché
la composition sera supérieure à sa
différence de prix donc ça nous
permettra de faire du social au dessus
de la compensation de 2 degrés donc
soyons clairs et le jeu qu'on le dit on
le répète non seulement on va pas
supprimer les subventions mais on va les
renforcer mais pour les familles
nécessiteuses gel des salaires le lien
des salaires bon on va pas geler les
salaires c'est sûr par ailleurs et
contenir la masse salariale dans des
proportions
qui sont permises par l'état des
finances publiques
ce n'est pas que mme avec l'inflation
qui est estimé à 8% cette année ça va
être difficile sur cmt pour les
syndicats par exemple la pression c'est
un phénomène mondial aujourd'hui et je
dirais même que le rythme de croissance
d'inflation incluse il est inférieur à
celui qu on observe deux compères dont
il convient d'avoir maintenant 7,5 on
était
si je sais à peu près et donc
là le rythme de croissance et les
raisonnables comparées à d'autres pays
quand je pense à l'espagne par exemple
récemment le rythme annuel et de 10% et
on est en train de faire le nécessaire
pour contrôler cette inflation même si
on pays vont payer un prix relativement
cher parce que la banque centrale vient
d'augmenter de
75 points de base ça va coûter les deux
directeurs et ont trompé le paie cher
mais c'est nécessaire à faire mais bon
je n'interfère pas dans l'édition de la
bourse entre al ahly autonome mais cela
permettra au moins de contrôler cette
saucisse cette inflation kéké qui ont
vous allez limiter les hausses de
salaire par dont les limites et les aux
le sanwi parce que en fait on n'a pas
les moyens de faire tomber un autre
endettement aujourd'hui il s'approche de
son prochain et donc on ne peut plus
nous permettre et un glissement est rien
d'effrayant empêche que nous travaillons
sur la réforme de la fonction publique
qui permettra parce que nous sommes
conscients que le niveau actuel des
salaires pour les cadres sont
particulièrement les cadres supérieurs à
80 de nbc ne sont pas satisfaits ce
n'est pas suffisant donc il faut une
réforme globale au niveau de la fonction
publique pour gagner également
productivité et tout ce qu'on est en
train de faire pour améliorer le climat
des affaires pour écrire la connaissance
ou fois nous avons la connaissance à ce
moment là nous pouvons partager il faut
lui la connaissance et moi je suis
partisan pour que partie généreuse
taille au travail on ne peut pas
distribuer ce qu'on n'a pas créé comme
richesse alors vous avez créé de la
dette vous l'avez dit 100% est ce qu'il
ya un risque de défaut de paiement de la
tunisie dans les mois à venir la tunisie
n'a jamais failli ils ont déjà d'autres
pays qui n'ont jamais brise qui on a vu
le sri lanka alors nous nous avons une
intensité de contraintes qui est qui qui
qui s'impose maintenant au monde entier
nous avons nos partenaires qui sont à
côté de nous maintenant et nous il n'est
pas à l'ordre du jour de fait le
quelconque défaillance donc nous on
renégociation de la dette tout à fait
non on n'est pas en train de le ce n'est
pas pour l'instant c'est une passe
potable et notre hypothèse de travail
notre objectif c'est de l'éviter parce
que on tient beaucoup à la qualité de la
signature de tunisie je le répète la
twizy n'a jamais failli à seyssinet
c'est pour ça que donne beaucoup
d'importance à cette discussion avec les
familles c'est le point de nous sommes
confiants que le jour reprend les
négociations pour mettre un programme
commun le redressement de l'économie ce
que ce que le mandat du pays nous allons
pouvoir avoir toutes les solutions
financières qu'une permettront de faire
face à ses engagements c'est merci merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu aux questions
de france merci à très merci à vous
d'avoir regardé cet entretien sur nos
antennes restez-y pour plus
d'informations
[Musique]